uh
all right if you are hearing this we are
going to get started in about five
minutes here once steve connects i am
just getting everything set up in the
back end so
thanks for your patience we'll start the
live stream in about five minutes
hmm
for those of you who are just joining us
we are just waiting a couple more
minutes to get started here we are doing
a live stream with steve kaufman in just
a minute
to go over
his progress towards learning arabic
so we will get started in about three
minutes or about two minutes now
and we will
be taking live questions once steve is
done with his presentation so sit tight
with us
you
hmm
alrighty
uh we've got steve kaufman joining us
steve can you hear me
looks like he's still getting connected
there you are
all right and i'm opening it up to
in uh steve how you doing hey not too
bad how are you i am doing great thank
you
excited to be here
all right
so
um just to give everyone a quick
introduction um i'm shelby smith head of
user onboarding here at link
and i'm joined by the
iconic steve kaufman
um we are all doing a 90-day challenge
with link that started on september 1st
but it's not too late for anyone who
hasn't joined a challenge yet
and these challenges are meant to keep
us engaged with our language learning
goals
language learning can be a difficult
road sometimes so we want to have these
events to be able to bring the community
together um you know get you guys to
interact with one another as well as be
able to learn from the master himself
steve is currently learning his 20th
language um which is arabic
around there maybe 25th
and um
he is going to be giving us a
presentation today a short you know 5-10
minute presentation on um
his tactics with achieving his goals in
arabic
um and we will also do a q a after that
so i've got some questions
that were submitted in advance we'll
start with those and then we will be
taking questions from those of you who
are on this zoom call today
um so feel free to use the chat for
people who are here on the zoom call um
you can use this to be submitting
questions um and interacting with one
another i'll also be sharing some links
with you guys in the chat
and um
so just on that note too if you guys do
want to ask a question just make sure to
use the chat today um since this is a
live stream on steve's channel um and so
i'll drop a link here in a second for
those of you who
need to get a link to join a link
challenge
um
shelby if i can interrupt something very
strange has happened to my screen i'm
now looking at someone else's desktop oh
claudia house tri boom huh
claudia it looks like you're sharing
your screen i will
um take care of this
here
i'm being hacked by claudia
ah there we go
all right
sorry about that steve
oh and now
now i'm
looking the wrong way there so there we
go there you are
this is our first time using this
streaming service for anyone curious so
we're all right here we go
okay with that being said steve um
would you please share with us a little
bit on you know your your tactics
you are getting from where you're at to
where you want to go right
okay so a couple of comments here first
of all it's very interesting uh watching
shelby we're by the way we're very happy
to have shelby as part of our team
and she's going to help make link easier
for people to understand and
make them enjoy using it more
and i noticed that shelby you like me
you tend to swing back and forth on your
chair that's good
sometimes i used to sit on one of these
swiss medicine balls so then i would be
jumping up and down the whole time
so all this stuff can happen we're
allowed to do what we want now i lost my
i lost you somehow oh we're here we're
here okay all right so
um yeah i think the and i i'm going to
go over sort of what i do
um i just saw a question pop up you know
what about hindi i want to learn hindi
uh with all uh these other languages we
won't be adding any languages until we
finish the rewrite
[Music]
all right unmute so again we won't be
adding languages until
we finish the you know version 5.0 of
link
which by the way i have been using in
beta form i'm not allowed to show it to
you but i enjoy i enjoy it very much
enough said i will show you
the older version which is what everyone
else has access to so with regard to
hindi we actually i gather have people
writing the many stories in hindi we
also have that in urdu we have that
actually in quite a number of languages
and once we have the rewrite done then
those languages will be uh introduced
that link so please be patient we want
to kind of stay on one task at a time
uh so
yeah the purpose of these is to show you
how link can help you stay motivated how
the 90-day challenge can help you stay
motivated
uh and i'm going to begin then i'm going
to start sharing my screen here uh
hopefully that works
uh
share no no no no no share content share
screen
okay
and uh
zoom yeah start broadcast hopefully this
is all going to work
everything's a bit of a mystery to me
so
you are sharing your screen except i
don't so maybe i got to get out of that
and can you see my screen now yeah
okay
so then i will go to uh link
here
okay can you all see that
yes
okay
so
uh
my uh arabic i sort of bounced back and
forth between the many stories and i'm
even doing the many stories in egyptian
arabic
uh which is easy because i've already
gone through the many stories in in
other languages and in standard arabic
and i'm doing the egyptian arabic
because occasionally there are egyptian
movies on netflix and i want to be able
to understand a bit more
because i come across a lot of words in
egyptian arabic that are very similar to
standard arabic it probably distorts my
numbers i give myself credit for more
you know words learned than than i
should because in fact i'm learning
words that i kind of more or less
already know so i bounce back and forth
spending maybe 10 20 percent of my time
on many stories either egyptian arabic
or standard arabic just to kind of get
the flow of the language
and then i go for more difficult stuff
and i have put them in this um course
here which i call happy scribe
because i use an automatic transcription
service called happyscribe
and so what happens is
my al jazeera podcast
i used to have this person in morocco
transcribed them for me
i'm not allowed to share them in the
library because we can't get any answer
from al jazeera
as to whether we can share them
but it ends up being expensive and two
three years ago i used an automatic
transcription service or two years ago
and it wasn't very good and for someone
learning the language
when you know it whereas it's supposed
to say i don't know independence and it
says tomato
that kind of throws you off the track so
i stopped using it i went back to paying
this person to just transcribe but now
the automatic transcription service is
very good i compared some of the
manually transcribed versions with the
automatically transcribed and they were
like 99 the same
so now i pay 10 a month for i don't know
12 hours
and so now because i have trouble
actually grabbing the mp3 files
from the al jazeera podcast site they
make it difficult for some reason but
the same lady in morocco is very skilled
at doing this so she sends me every week
three or four
mp3 files that she's extracted somehow
and then i put them on to happyscribe
and then i
i start studying them and this is more
difficult content before i go through
one of these uh sorry
before i go through one of these lessons
let's have a look at my uh statistics
so this last week
uh i
acquired 660 known words
i ignore my automatically generated
goals
i just know that i would like to do
about 100 new known words
every day
with some slippage so if it's 500 a week
that'll be good because
i want to increase my known words total
my known words total now is 15
794. bear in mind that there are some
egyptian arabic words that had a
before it and but it's still obvious
that it's
it's a word that i already knew so maybe
that number should be less by a factor
it doesn't really matter to me
it's just it's like uh i often refer to
it to the the statistics as like the
in the greyhound races
they have a mechanical rabbit if you've
ever seen
heart a greyhound like dog races they
had them in macau
and so there's a mechanical rabbit that
charges down the side of the track and
all the dogs go chasing after the
the mechanical rabbit so these
statistics are kind of like that
mechanical rabbit
they're not you don't necessarily want
to
you know brag to people that you know
this many words because depending on the
language
you know you may have very many
different forms of the same word so
that'll inflate your known words
statistic
so it's just an indicator so i want to
have 100 known words a day or let's say
over between five to seven hundred known
words a week so this past week i have
660 known words that i have added to my
known words total i'm happy
the links created these are the two that
i paid the most attention to
but mostly known words because
if i look here
at say all time
did i hit no wait a second
all time so
i have 52 000 saved links
but i have uh only 15 000 known words so
i have saved over 50 000 words and
phrases
but i only know
you know about thirty percent of them
so if i want and my goal is to get to
where i understand
the podcast better like right now if i
get these podcast mp3 files
and i listen to it i understand 15 20 i
catch words here and there
if i if there are a lot of words strung
together that then i understand that
little bit of meaning but if the words
that i understand are you know in
between a whole bunch of words that i
don't understand then i don't really get
the meaning
so i can't just grab the podcast and run
uh but i'd like to get to the point
where in the morning as i come up and
make breakfast and i just go to the
podcast site i grab a podcast it's new
because new is good fresh is good it's
today's news it's more fun to do
something new than to go over a lesson
that you've gone over five times and you
still don't remember all the words and
but after a while it's just the brain
wants novelty so i want to get to the
point where i can just grab a podcast on
the fly
in my car or while working around the
house and understand it so i have to
increase my known words total so my goal
here is to get to 20 i'd like to get to
20 000 known words
so so that's the main thing that i
target so if i look at my today
all right today i haven't done much
uh even if i look at yesterday i had a
bit of a a weekend where i played golf
and did a bunch of other stuff
and so i didn't do much
so today i'm kind of motivated to make
sure i hit that
you know adding a hundred known words
and the links the links will come by
themselves so if i go back to my
happy scribe here
so this is the i received from my uh
moroccan collaborator
i received
uh
september 28th one two three four of
them so i just call them i just put them
into this course happy scribe
and i just number them on the date that
she sends them to me just so that i can
tell them apart
and you'll see
that i'm running about 15 18 14
new words in these podcasts so there was
a time not so long ago
when
these were running
30 40 unknown words so even though i'm
struggling to understand them
and i'm not necessarily aware of a big
improvement
i do feel sometimes that i have made
turned a corner and then the next time i
get another
you know podcast i don't understand it
very well and so this can be a little
frustrating but i know from these
statistics
that uh i'm running 15
so
i'm a lot better than i was
and each one of these if you'll see
again you know it has like 100 in the
first one september the 28th the first
one has 194 blue words now some of those
will be place names
which i won't count
but if i go through that whole lesson i
will add 100 links or more
but there are also 416
yellow words in there and those are the
ones that i really want to get after
because i want to move them to known
wherever i can so one of the techniques
that i use so we'll get into the lesson
here
all right so here and of course here we
are looking at the first page now i've
been through some of this that's why
so much of it is yellow so i can tell
just by looking at this page that i've
done the first three paragraphs by the
way uh shelby is this good can you
comment is is this making sense because
i'm just talking and i don't know how
this is being received oh yeah yeah we
can yeah okay everything clearly
all right
super so so typically what i do now
is i know that i'm here in this uh in
this uh fourth paragraph which i've
started into
uh and what i then do is i will go into
the
sentence view because i prefer to review
these in sentence view sentence view has
a big advantage in that there's an
automatically generated translation
which which may not be
always
totally you know correct or accurate or
makes sense but it gives you a bit of a
hint and so then i would work my way
through these
uh
and so now
i
you know
go to the next page i like to start to
where there's wherever there's a blue
word
so i see this i go through it
uh and i go through and and uh
you know
the alpha well
guess see
i know that's a guest so i may i may be
tempted here
to say i know that word
one of the troubles of course in arabic
is is trying to read it and particularly
now that i'm under more pressure as i'm
making a presentation
but
however that's pronounced the ifa the
alpha i get confused sometimes what do
they say
okay i can't hear anyway let's say i
know that i move it to three
and i'm going to show you why i do that
i like to move my words to three
so that because any word that's in
status three
uh which you know
means that i'm close to knowing it
and so wherever i can i move my words
you know
this is
musadar is a source i know that
sources musa sources
so that's a two i can move that to a
three i'm almost to the point where i
know that
uh
so
i don't know what that is
clashes all right i don't know that
stays a one okay
is that to support i don't know dummy oh
that's a place okay if it's a place then
i have to make this
a uh so i just go x i don't want this
word
all right here so
i don't want it because i don't take i
don't claim credit for
uh place names so
i won't go through the rest of it but
what i wanted to show you then if i quit
this
and i go to my vocabulary section
so i have all my words now that i have
saved
and i have different ways of sorting
them so i can go and say i only want to
look at what are known as familiar words
category three words because those are
the words that i'm most likely
to get close to moving to know
i could
add as a filter tags if i only wanted to
look at verbs for example
or if i want them all to come from a
particular course
uh and i can sort them by creation date
by importance by status whatever but i'm
gonna just go after all the words are in
category three and let me know shelby if
this doesn't make sense so then i hit
apply
so now i have all my category three
words
so
these are words that i have a high
probability like if there are i don't
know what it is 20 per page
probably i'm going to be able to pick
off five ten of these that i can move to
know so when i wanna batch i wanna make
sure
that i hit my targets because it's very
satisfying to know that you've hit the
target you know if the goal is i want to
listen a lot
that's not as good as
i have to listen an hour or i have to
add
100 words to my known words total or i
have to create 100 links so if it's four
in the afternoon
and i see that i have only added 60 then
i'll go back in there and do it again
it's a bit again like the mechanical
rabbit
it's something that just forces you you
want to chase that target you want to
make sure you hit that target and that
then a lot of good things happen so
again i'm not going to go through these
but i know from experience and one thing
you can also do
is if you press on this
you know you get a little counter so
what happens is like if i go through 10
pages here
and i managed to find you know 100 words
that i can move to known
and bear in mind that i can move them to
known and move them back again and the
statistics adjust so i give myself the
benefit of the doubt so i said yeah i
know this later on i feel not quite so
comfortable i move it back so we can
always move back and forth from known to
three to two sometimes sometimes i got a
little
you know
ambitious and and gave myself credit for
a word that actually i really don't know
so i move it back to two but by and
large 90 95 percent of the time once
i've moved it to known
it stays there
and so if i've done 10 or 15 pages i
remember that i got to page 15. so when
i go back there
rather than starting from page one again
because in all there's like 50 pages
um i'll start at page 15. so i just go
apply
all right
and so now i'm at page 15. so this is
just one i just wanted to share this as
as as a strategy in other words when
you're reading
you know move the status along like i
know the status moves along by say doing
flash cards i don't do a lot of flash
cards so i move them manually
certainly they move from blue to yellow
that is status one but i move it to
status too which isn't a great big step
but
even the fact that you are
taking the time to move it to status 2
is you're focusing on it a little bit
it helps then you move it to status 3
and then you get to review it again in
the vocab section or you come across it
in the text and you move it to know and
in this way
uh i am hoping
that i'm going to be able to get my
known words total up to about 20 000
and and ultimately the test will be
do i understand
do i understand um my podcast better now
one last thing
uh let's get back to my lessons one last
thing i should say
is that uh in addition to
this uh where are we here uh my lessons
i have
also started
speaking
so i have now got these conversation
reports
and i've started speaking quite a lot
because
i feel i'm at the stage now where i want
to start speaking more
and maybe
the end of the month here i may have
uh say if i can get my have a tutor in
egypt
uh muhammad who's a great guy
sends excellent uh reports
full of all the errors that i made let's
just look at the
the and and he's just uh he's just a
great guy and i enjoy talking to him and
he sends very thorough uh reports with
all the mistakes and and phrases that i
struggled with
and uh so i am starting to talk more
uh it helps me of course improve my
speaking ability it also makes me
realize where i have trouble for example
the verbs
which reminds me which reminds me
that um
[Music]
let's see uh
so let's see if if i can pick a verb
uh dictionaries
this
if if it covers it let's have a look
here there we go so i am using the
reversal conjugation dictionary which
exists in a number of languages
i used it for greek
uh
certainly you know french italian
spanish and so anytime you're on a verb
you can then look at
all of the various conjugations of that
verb
and it'll even highlight the particular
form that you're dealing with
and i know this is all uh not many
people are doing arabic but the same
works for a lot of languages where the
reverso conjugator exists
and it verbs in many languages are so
difficult
that just to have a chance to kind of go
over it you know without trying to
remember it
and when you see a verb you know which
partic part which form of the verb is
this and then you review the whole table
of conjugations i find that
you know helpful in in trying to you
know master
i shouldn't say master but get a better
handle on
on this stuff now i got to figure out
how i get to unsharing
shelby can you help me i forgot now yeah
um so there should be like a stop
broadcast or and i think it was end
broadcast on your side and broadcast
yeah oh maybe i go to zoom ah here we
are yeah stop share okay
screen
start video wait a second oh it's live
broadcast i stopped okay
and stopped it okay did that work yeah
yeah all right
the presentation steve um i mean and for
those of you who joined us a little bit
late steve is sharing how he is using
link
and he mentioned in the beginning he's
been using the link 5.0 beta so we were
showing you guys on link 4.0 um which is
something that he hasn't been using so
much lately
um but he's using his ipad first of all
so um he he really loves using it on the
ipad i'm i'm now thinking that i need to
invest in an ipad because
link works so great on it
and
he's sharing i saw we got a question in
german here claudia i'm not sure if you
um understand english but i don't speak
german so to answer the question um
steve is learning arabic now so that's
why this presentation is about his
arabic learning right if i could
interrupt shelby i mean i could have
chosen spanish or french or anything
else which more people are familiar with
but it wouldn't be realistic because
that's not what i'm doing what i'm doing
right now is learning arabic but the
principle applies to all languages
exactly
so thanks steve i think that was really
um informational and or informative and
um i was gonna say oh when he was
showing the vocabulary section too of
course you can always click that orange
yellow review button and do the flash
cards but as steve said he prefers to
just do it in a list and you can do it
that way too so
link is extremely customizable that's
one of the reasons that we do these
sessions so that you get a chance to see
how other people are using link
so let's get into some questions we had
a great question submitted by
user timothy last week on the zoom call
and i thought this might be very
relevant for you steve um he asked if
anyone knows of some good places to imb
import arabic stories for beginner level
um is that something okay
all right so um
first of all we have our many stories
that link
that's what i use because
um
typically with stories with sort of
random stories beginner stories
theoretically they're easy and sometimes
their children's stories but i find
there's often not a lot of repetition of
the vocabulary
they don't necessarily focus on high
frequency verbs sometimes they introduce
because their children's stories you
know fox and wolf and bear
you know animals and stuff like that
which is not necessarily vocabulary that
that's easy to learn or that we're that
interested in however we do have there
is a person
gosh matthew aldridge
and it's called
lingualism
lingua and then
lism lingualism
you can google for it he also has some
of his stories available at link
and those are he's got a series called
mo modo or something in other words
stories intended for
uh beginners and so you can certainly
look for them we actually there's a fair
amount of other than the mini stories
and of course who is she
which is also available in arabic and
and again both of them the audio quality
is excellent but there are other
beginner materials available at link so
that would be my suggestion check out
lingualism
anytime you google you know arabic
stories you'll find a whole bunch of i
spent a lot of time doing this trying to
find material to supplement what we had
at link but in the end i just ended up
using what we had at link
and then graduated from that to the
podcast
awesome thanks and i shared the link to
lingualism in this
so we always get um questions about how
to improve pronunciation
steve you just shared that you've been
speaking with your tutor um so can you
share
first of all how how long did you start
how long were you reading arabic for
before you begin to speak and now that
you are speaking how frequently do you
speak
well uh
you know it used to be that i would wait
a long time
i would wait till i had fifteen thousand
words say in czech or russian
uh with the many stories i started
earlier
and and if there's some other you know
reason this there has to be a reason to
start speaking so
when i said i'm going to learn three
languages persian arabic and turkish
then i kind of committed to doing a sort
of an exit video after three months so
of course i i don't want to look
completely stupid so i started speaking
uh you know ahead of that exit video
my impression on the pronunciation is
you you have to hear a lot of the
language before you can speak
you have to hear what you're going to
pronounce and very often we don't hear
it at first it takes quite a while
before we start to hear
clearly how the language is pronounced
some people think that if you start
speaking too early you might sort of
ingrain some
because you haven't quite heard it
correctly and you start then pronouncing
what you hear
and then you might not
pronounce correctly and you may not be
able to correct that pronunciation i
have no proof that that's the case i
even doubt that that's the case some
people say that but i don't see any
particular advantage in trying to speak
too early
uh
i find the many stories because there's
so much repetition
is very helpful in terms of getting a
bit of a rhythm in the language
uh
other than that in order to improve your
pronunciation many people have pointed
out that this what
the intonation the rhythm of the
language is often as important as the
individual sounds so if you get the
rhythm
you know the example of french you know
because in english we have a lot of sort
of up and down when we speak the
language and of course the french they
speak it's more it's more monotonous
and
if you're speaking french with a typical
uh
java parlez francais then you get too
much of this english intonation into
your french and if you try and imitate
the intonation of the language it helps
you with your pronunciation i also think
it's very useful
to
you know go
use sentence view on link
and
and of course any of the link content
for example the many stories or who is
she
is time stamped by us
because we can control it it's our
material so we time stamp it so you can
hear the natural voice saying the
sentence and so a sentence is a chunk of
text that's it's relatively easy to
listen to and then repeat and then
repeat
with the intonation that you just heard
even if you mispronounce a word or two
focus totally on the intonation
if you graduate so those are the kinds
of things and if you graduate beyond
that you might go paragraph at a time
listening to the natural uh speech and
then trying to imitate that so i would
put a major emphasis on uh intonation
and i wouldn't worry unduly about the
sort of the the difficult sounds that so
that trilled r in spanish or the
guttural are in french trying to nail
those down every language has a few
sounds like in arabic it's just ah
i haven't got it you know there's no way
i can do it properly
uh i wouldn't worry overly about the
sort of small number of sounds that
cause difficulty and focus rather on the
the intonation and and uh using uh
sentence mode particularly with say who
is she or the many stories and listening
to the natural speech one sentence at a
time and trying to capture that
intonation i think that can help
great steve thank you so much um
so
we are now getting into some questions
that were um submitted during the call
and they're continuing to come in so
thanks guys keep asking questions if
they come up
so um
from brazil
um
asked about
uh to do
how do i learn languages with link since
certain languages do not have the text
to speech function oh and he wants you
to answer in portuguese i think we're
going to keep the answers in english for
the sake of today's call
but okay
we can always like we can follow up with
an email as well
if you if you need that to be in
portuguese
first of all i did an interview with uh
a brazilian
uh in portuguese so that should be put
up on my on my channel shortly and we
should maybe have a session
with our brazilian friends
purely in portuguese where they can ask
all the questions they want in
portuguese and it'll all be in
portuguese for portuguese speakers so
that's an event that we should plan for
because we've had one in russian for
example and i think we should have one
in portuguese uh yeah there is an issue
with the languages for which there is no
text to speech i experience that problem
with persian farsi they don't have text
to speech it's a lot more difficult i
wish they had text-to-speech we've tried
we can't get
uh you know because with these
text-to-speech things we go to providers
this is not our software and we have to
go with the best service that covers the
largest possible number of languages and
for whatever reason
farsi or persian isn't there so what do
i do i just use that five second repeat
button so i'll study sentence mode and
i'll just go five second repeat five
second repeat and so
uh
and and i'll tell you it's very
difficult in persian because the arabic
script it's not always obvious how the
word is pronounced so whereas if you're
reading in portuguese you can tell how
it's pronounced even if you don't know
the meaning of the word because the
spelling is so consistent whereas in
persian and in arabic that's not the
case so it is a problem i wish we had
text to speech use the five second
five second repeat button and i gather
that i shouldn't talk too much about 5.0
but one of the things they're planning
to do is to make it possible for people
to more easily timestamp things so if
i'm listening to something in persian
then i can timestamp
the uh
the thing so that i get the audio
for that sentence so when we have that
capability it'll make it a lot easier
but that's about the best i can do
yeah and i would add that the
text-to-speech is great but
it doesn't sound like a natural person
speaking in most cases so
it's important to not be reliant on that
and you know it's a good idea to
actually listen to the way native
speakers talk in the lesson audios
but i would just tell you that in those
languages where the writing system is
not consistent such as english for
example you know
though through
uh whatever you know i mean it can be
pronounced in any number of ways very
often
uh you need the text to speech so know
how to pronounce the word so that uh
text-to-speech is very important
actually to to grab the pronunciation of
a word
or a phrase in those languages where the
writing system is not consistent in
spanish obviously that's not an issue
because you can pronounce anything you
read once you understand you know the
value of of the letters in spanish
right right and i was just saying um
like the the audio of the native speaker
actually speaking like on a you know on
a podcast
right you can't compete with that um i
can't possibly listen to the whole thing
in texas speech i agree with you that's
just not very pleasant
so um
we this is another question that comes
up nicholas asked today if it's
ill-advised to try and learn um two or
more languages at the same time
um
perhaps the brain can handle that no
problem or is it better to focus on a
single language objective
um
i mean steve i know you've been
learning three languages
but you've been focusing more on arabic
it seems so can you talk a little bit
about that experience so i mean it
depends on your goals obviously if your
goal is to learn one language then the
more time you spend on that one language
the faster you're going to progress
so then i was kind of faced with this
issue i would like to learn three middle
eastern languages arabic persian and
turkish
so
if i were to spend say three years on
arabic then i would be nowhere in my
persian or turkish at the end of three
years
so i said well i'll try learning the
three at the same time
that was a bit too much
but at least i have a sense of each of
those languages now which i enjoy which
i enjoy i know how those languages work
to some extent i have some words so i'm
glad i did that but then i decided so in
other words what i'm saying is it
entirely depends on your goals and then
i said to myself well
turkish while it's a difficult language
and it's different it's written in the
latin alphabet so it's easier so i can
go back to that later so let's put that
aside so i parked my turkish but i can
go back to what i did
and it's not lost
but i want to get better at reading the
arabic script which is used in persian
and arabic so i focus on those two
languages then came this 90-day
challenge and i said okay well let's
totally focus on arabic for these 90
days
definitely i am progressing more quickly
in my arabic now than i was when i was
sharing my time between arabic and
persian
the good thing about about doing two
languages is that
any learning activity
or you're focused on focused on one
activity
there is an element of fatigue because
you're doing the same thing
so to that extent if say after two or
three days of arabic i was tired of my
arabic i'd go to my persian and it was
fun again
and i kind of rediscovered it again and
so that i i it can be quite stimulating
and and you know
more fun
but
it means that in a given week
uh
you know going back to my statistics
i'll have instead of having five or six
hundred new known words in arabic it'll
only be three hundred
so so you it really depends on what you
wanna do it's not impossible to do
uh certainly there are many places in
the world where school kids learn more
than one language
and i don't think they do any worse than
say
english-speaking canadian kids who spend
10 years on french and don't learn
anything
so they don't do any worse doing two
languages they probably do better i
suspect that the student in germany who
does french and
and italian probably learns better than
the student in canada who isn't very
motivated and doesn't learn any french
so it all depends on your motivation too
right yeah absolutely i think what you
said in the beginning um is the the crux
of the answer which is that it does
depend on your goals but the short
answer is yes you can learn multiple
languages at once you're gonna probably
be a little bit slower to get to the the
more advanced or fluent um you you
certainly will be slower i mean
but the languages you can confuse them
yes they can also help each other though
too and i think
to your last point steve
language learning is
it's a it's a
form of learning in the brain you know
so
the better you get at learning languages
i think the better you get at learning
languages you know like so each one
yes they can get confused sometimes but
that's just a minor low impact problem
it's not going you're not going to get
stuck on that confusion forever you know
you're going to figure it out pretty
quickly actually
so
that's low impact and overall um
language learning i think
is a great skill to develop and i think
steve is a is a living living proof that
it's it's great for your brain
yeah and i i compare it sometimes to
sports like they've often said like if
kids only play one sport like
sometimes say here in canada there's a
over concentration on hockey actually if
the kids also go and play tennis and
play soccer and play other sports it
makes them better in the hockey so i
think there's a bit of that in languages
too that
for the brain to get a little more
flexible and study other languages it's
it's also it has its positive side and
and the the interference thing is not a
big deal
not a big i agree with you low impact
not a not a big problem
great analogy i love that
so we got some more questions coming in
here um
oscar says hi steve i'm learning
japanese from a one level
i find your japanese videos helpful and
enjoyable
i have a question about comprehensible
input versus compelling input
is it good to listen to more advanced
compelling content where i understand
about 15 to 20 percent
um he says he enjoys listening to them
even if he doesn't understand much at
this moment
um or is it better to listen to more
beginner level content to acquire words
gradually and easier
you know again i think uh i'm in the
same position it's that 15 is about
where i am on my uh al jazeera podcast
um i think you know
it's important to vary things and and
it's important to do what you feel like
doing
so there's no question that it is often
very pleasant to listen to material
that's relatively easy
i do re-listen to my many stories
particularly if i want something that's
not too demanding uh i'm doing the
dishes or i'm working or whatever so
this thing's just going on in the
background i notice some things i fade
out i get back in again
so that's
you know uh can be fun but then after
about two or three many stories i'm
bored
so then i go and grab something that's
actually
interesting so this first podcast from
al jazeera was about
you know unrest in egypt and so forth so
uh you know the subject matter is itself
interesting so i think that the answer
is you want to vary it and and be guided
by what you feel like doing
and don't feel that you should be
obligated to the to do the one or the
other and whatever you are doing
while you're doing it stay with it like
don't you know it's very easy to sort of
be in a difficult thing oh this is doing
this too difficult go back to the
ministers ah this is boring go back to
the difficult stuff so you're constantly
flipping back and forth i mean you got
to give it a
you know give it a chance like stay with
the one or the other stay with it for a
certain period of time and then
you can move back to whatever you know
to the more difficult so and and
obviously you know this comprehensible
input we got to be careful like if you
start in the language nothing is
comprehensible so
you have to struggle
uh at first and and even when you're
going to
compelling content some of it may also
not be very comprehensible so so that
it's a constant balance i think each
person should should kind of plot that
for themselves
yeah and one thing that i come back to
is one of your um seven secrets for
success with language learning and you
said to
do what you like to do and with link
this is the first time that i have
really
loved language learning because it's
hard to learn languages but if you have
the opportunity to study content that
you love
even if it's
way above your skill level
i would say oscar like do what you like
to do best and
um
i also think it's important to challenge
yourself you know you shouldn't
necessarily be 100 comfortable uh in the
lessons that you study and and like
steve said too have some variety you
know maybe go back and forth and do the
challenging stuff for the bulk of it and
then go you know hit the weights in the
gym with your mini stories and you're
going to be like wow i'm pretty good at
these mini stories right now after
doing more studying more advanced
content
totally agree
um awesome so we're getting a lot more
questions streaming in here's a more
simple one and steve i don't know if you
commented on this when you were doing
when you were showing the
vocabulary review
how long do you spend reviewing
vocabulary per day
uh again i wish we had
you know some system on link that would
measure the amount of time you spend on
different activities i'm curious i don't
know
uh and you can often think that you know
you can totally
you know be wildly off some i tend to
underestimate the amount of time i spend
i probably spend more time than i think
but i'm not i'm not if there's not a
time thing there i say i need my 100 new
word
you know i need to add 100 known words
to my total so i'll bang bang bang bang
okay how many have i got i'll go and
check my statistics so i only added 50.
i'll do another 20. now i'm tired of
doing it i'll go back to reading
something or whatever so
i'm not guided by time but
i would say that uh probably
you know i i i so people ask me how much
time do you spend oh i spend an hour
listening and then i spend half hour
reading that's not true in fact i spend
more time than that so i spent that hour
of listening that's easy because you
know it's 20 minutes making breakfast 15
20 minutes cleaning up i work out i'm in
the car so that's an hour that's easy
but i spend more time than that because
i'll typically you know in the evening
after dinner or maybe in the afternoon
or sometimes in the morning i'll work a
bit on the ipad
and uh once i get in there and i'm
moving words to none
that ends up ends up being half an hour
45 minutes and now i'm speaking to my
tutor for an hour every
second day or every day so i'm actually
spending three hours a day now not not
not my one and a half
so uh yeah i tend to underestimate the
amount of time i spend but
on the vocabulary section again i am
driven by the sort of uh
target of moving getting a hundred new
known words so once i've achieved that i
don't go back there once i got my 100 i
don't want to do any more because then i
want to get credit for those the next
day
so i leave them now i'll go back to them
later on
sure and um you also you know we have to
watch out for fatigue too if you spend
hours and hours on end drilling
vocabulary
i would probably get bored and
tired um from doing that for too long so
as someone who recently started
practicing french i mean steve you've
been doing er how long have you been
learning oh
it's two years like you mix in the
turkish and the farsi and the odd trip
that i took with my wife and so it's not
like every day
but i've been at it for two years
right and that's what it takes like i
have no illusions
that's what it takes it takes even if i
had been on arabic full-time i'd be
further ahead but
we're talking it's a long it's a
complicated language it's not like going
like with you and knowing spanish your
french is not going to take you that
long
but uh yeah it takes time
yeah and and so where i'm at since i'm a
few months into learning french i'm
doing about an hour of lessons a day of
reading and and i do i spend more time
listening when i'm out and about or not
really out and about these days but when
i'm here sitting at my desk working um
so that adds up to i don't know how many
hours of listening
but
i probably spend maximum 15 minutes a
day doing vocabulary review at my stage
where i'm at
maybe i could stand to do a little bit
more
one thing about vocabulary review
everyone approaches it differently
for me i find doing flashcards is very
tedious like i can't do it for more than
five minutes so i don't do it i i
sometimes do it maybe turning the page
in a lesson i might review
newly
newly learned words like that i've just
looked up so for me i go down the list
it's just exposure and all i do is say
do i know i don't know this i don't know
this i don't yeah i know this one i
don't know i don't know yeah i know this
one i don't i don't know so that's the
process it's not racking my brain to try
and remember anything it's either i know
it or i don't know it so it's just
exposure
great
so we have a really interesting question
here
um brahim asked
when you learn a new language do you
think in your mother tongue to speak or
do you have uh or do you have another
way
um
you know this is a a
very common question
i think that when we start a new
language of course we think in our
mother tongue
because there's this gradual process
where we everything comes from mother
tongue that's the only point of
reference we have all these words are
new so we're converting them to our
native language or a language that we
know very very well right
and then gradually some words they start
to have meaning you know without
reference to your native language and
pretty soon some bits of
text start to have meaning in and of
themselves without reference to your
native language this is a very gradual
process so only in the languages that i
speak the best am i totally free from my
native language i'm just speaking in
that language reacting to that language
but in languages that i don't speak so
well
i'm kind of thinking it out in my native
language or a language that i know
and then saying it a lot of the time not
all the time and then as i speak that
language more as i read and listen more
in that language then the amount of time
that in my that i'm in my native
language becomes less and less but it's
a gradual process but at the beginning
absolutely you're relying on your native
language
that's all you got
yeah exactly and i think that is the
long-term goal you know once you can
really start speaking and understanding
in your target language that's when
you're really internalizing it
so let's see here um we've got more
questions streaming in a lot of that are
kind of repeated that we've gone over a
couple times
um
hameed sorry if i got that pronunciation
wrong
um
is it possible for an arabic speaker to
develop an american accent and sound
like a native american speaker
well in theory anybody can learn any
accent
and uh you know we typically tend to
think of say
chinese people as having trouble
developing a
native sounding american accent let's
say but yet i know
uh immigrants here in canada
uh who haven't been here that long and
who speak very very well and others who
don't so it's very individual i think it
depends on on
how much listening you do it depends
also on an attitude those people who
seem to speak the most naturally in
another language including the
pronunciation they're people who have a
lot of friends
in the local say if you're if you're
living in the states saying you have a
lot of friends and you're with them a
lot and you you want to kind of be in
with that group and so you start to
identify with that group and you start
to imitate how they speak and so forth
so i think there's so many factors that
influence it uh
by the same token i would say that the
number of people who are like totally to
be mistaken for a native is very very
small if i look at some of the truly
outstanding polyglots
that you can find on the internet like
luca lamporiello who speaks
flawless english flawless everything
uh
and he his english is flawless it's very
close to native but it's not native so
you can get very close
and and obviously the native is the
model you want to imitate
but you don't have to speak you don't
have to be mistaken for a native
and i think sometimes that's a
a goal that people set for themselves
it's far more important to use the
language well i know people here
who you know that i encounter in work or
whatever
and they just speak so well they speak
better than native speakers their
choice of words their vocabulary how
they express themselves everything is
very you know
elegant and accurate and so forth and
yet they have an accent and it doesn't
matter and it's far better to use the
language well with an accent as opposed
to you know hi how you doing trying to
pretend you're an american you know
and yet you can't speak very well so put
the emphasis on on speak using words
well
and and that the accent will come
i couldn't agree more um i studied
spanish for all of high school and then
i stopped practicing for several years
and then i moved to
ecuador and in ecuador they speak really
nice
um spanish it sounds a lot like mexican
spanish in my opinion
and i thought i was doing well there
but when i moved to chile which is a
completely different dialect i could not
understand anyone and they could not
understand me
so i had a lovely friend who a local
friend who was very honest with me and
she said you have to work on your accent
in that you have to work on your
pronunciation of the words
so i started focusing on that and as i
immersed myself more and more with the
chileans i started developing their
dialect and over time they started to
kind of laugh and say oh you kind of
speak with a chilean accent but of
course i wasn't necessarily fooling
anyone
um that was chilean that thought i was
from there but
i i agree with you steve it's the goal
you wanna you wanna use that as the
guide and
and aim for that but
unless you really need to fool someone
it's not necessary
you're a spy you know
um but just look at the movie stars
sometimes they they do a great job
developing a new accent
but that's their business
okay
an actor
he or she
they're and that's a good point because
they're able to project themselves into
another role they have to be that role
so if you want to speak like an american
you have to almost project yourself i am
an american so you have to play that
role and that's why the actors are so
good at it
yeah and i would say if you really want
to develop that you should watch a lot
of
tv too in that
dialect of the language that you're
going for and even
songs like just ways to pick up on slang
and the way that people are actually
using the language if that's your goal
interesting question here we only have a
couple more minutes so we'll get a
couple quick ones out of the way
do you ever get tired or have you ever
gotten tired of studying a particular
language to the point of even resenting
it
the biggest frustration in the language
is the sort of inability to find content
that is both interesting and accessible
so that was a problem for me with korean
and i did find these podcasts that were
good and at that time the happy
transcriber the automatic transcription
service wasn't available so i was paying
someone to transcribe him it was very
difficult
i was spending all his money and i kind
of lost interest to some extent i think
now if i were to go back to korean
then i would use this automatic
transcription and i would go for things
of interest
we also have the ability now to go to
youtube and bring content in with with
subtitles so there's a whole range of
content out there now that would be
accessible to me but where i become a
little frustrated is when i i'm kind of
tired of doing the sort of beginner
stuff oh and we didn't have many stories
in korean either so we had the sort of
very childish and boring beginner
material that's just
you know in korean there's just so much
of it and there's not a lot of
intermediate or accessible intermediate
or slightly difficult content so that
was frustrating to me that's the only
time that's the only time um i have no
sense of frustration with what i'm doing
in arabic and farsi now and i'm just
discovering more and more about that
part of the world and it's interesting
yeah and remember the idea with link is
to
to practice what you enjoy
exactly
so we'll take uh two more questions we
have um one from a user who is doubting
the effectiveness of
listening while doing other tasks
cooking driving cleaning etc i know that
that's a huge
i mean that's a huge source of your
practice or it has been in the past
steve and and maybe it varies based on
where you're at in in learning a certain
language but um this user is saying that
um he doesn't he doesn't understand the
effectiveness of it if you're really new
in um in a language like if you're a
total beginner you're listening to a
podcast or whatever and you can only
understand maybe 10 to 15 percent
is that actually
time where you're learning
or do you need to be more at 40 to 60
before you start listening like that
when you're doing other tasks
so if i take the example of
persian arabic and turkish
when i started in those languages or
greek for that matter i was at zero
comprehension zero
and if i review my statistics on my
playlist i have listened to
the various mini stories 30 40 50 times
and when i i remember when i started
listening to persian or arabic it was
just noise i didn't understand a thing
and i would listen then i would go and
read it look up words listen again look
at words and slowly like this great big
jigsaw puzzle
a few pieces start to
become you know start to become clearer
and the net
result was that at the end of uh two
three months
i understood the first 10 15 20 stories
quite well
the next 10 15 20 not quite as well and
struggled with
the last 20 stories so all i'm and the
bulk of my study time was listening
while doing other tasks
so if i listen to the stories 30 times i
maybe re-read them five times so that
overwhelmingly my study time was
listening and it wasn't i never ever
just sit down and listen because when i
do that my mind wanders i just don't
have the ability to sit there and just
do nothing and sit in my chair and
listen so it was all
listening while doing other tasks so the
result was that at the end of three
months well the result was you can see
my exit videos in persian the arabic is
not
fair because i had been doing it before
that but if you look at the persian and
turkish exit videos that is essentially
three months of listening to many
stories or mostly like the odd bit of
more interesting content but
overwhelmingly listening 10 20 30 40
times too many stories and then i was
able to communicate and that is
essentially listening while doing other
tasks so for me it works
that's all i can say
yeah everyone is different and i we
highly encourage you to experiment and
and one other tip that steve gives in
his um seven
video secrets to success um is to learn
to notice you know even if you're only
understanding
10 15
try to notice any word that you
might understand and as you hear it in
various contexts it starts to have more
meaning to you and it's embedded more
deeply in you so i i also believe that
at the early stage that i'm at in my
french for example i will listen to
songs that go fast that you know use
tons of words that i don't know in
french and i still try to notice and i
think it's helping me but stay tuned
one thing i would add like okay french
in a way for an english speaker and
especially someone who knows spanish is
a little easier because words are
recognizable not necessarily at first
but pretty soon you see where they're
similar to words that you know
in arabic that's not the case like
there's nothing
and and so what starts to happen is you
start you mention so you talk about
noticing what you start to notice is
you start to hear words you don't know
what the word means but you now hear
that this is a word and this is a word
so you start to sort of tell where one
word ends and the next word begins
that's the first step in noticing so i
wanted that's an early stage in noticing
which is very important
and developing your ear for the language
exactly you're developing you see that
these are the the divisions between
words now you got to look those words up
and and then you don't remember what you
looked up and then you look it up again
and you don't remember and all of this
is happening but you at least you're
able to identify the sort of individual
words and what you're listening to
the second thing about noticing that's
very important is i can go back to um
you know a mini story in arabic that
i've listened to 40 times
and i've been off listening to al
jazeera and i go back to that mini story
and i will notice things
things aspects of grammar structure word
use and stuff
that maybe i've come across it elsewhere
and all of a sudden i notice it in the
mini story whereas i hadn't noticed it
before it's amazing the amount of stuff
that goes by you that you don't notice
but at a certain point you start to
notice and that's why the ability to
notice is also dependent on lots of
input
because after a while you just notice
more and more things and there's tons of
stuff to notice tons of stuff to notice
anyway
so
we have a lot more questions um most of
them we've answered in some format or
another earlier in the call so you guys
can uh this is recorded and it'll be
viewable on steve's youtube channel the
link facebook page we have one final
question it's a quick one ibrahim said
hi steve are you planning to go to an
arabic speaking country after the
challenge i invite you to egypt
okay
i would love to visit an arabic speaking
country i have been to one two actually
i've been to jordan and i've been to
morocco
uh now people say about morocco they
speak a different arabic blah blah blah
that's true but i found that taxi
drivers there was a lady who ran a
restaurant and
with my you know limited standard arabic
they were definitely very nice about
humoring me in standard arabic
uh
egypt my current
tutor
is from egypt a super nice guy
uh
i would love to go i think egypt i i'm
beginning to develop this a bit of a
fascination for egypt because it's the
largest arabic speaking country
and it's the center of the film industry
my wife and i have looked at a few
egyptian uh
series on netflix
and they're kind of nice to have a bit
of an oldie worldly
feel to them not so much sort of
violence and stuff
so i yeah i'm tempted to go there and
but i wanna i wanna be at a level in my
arabic that i can really take advantage
and uh i find that to really take
advantage of being in the country where
they speak the language you gotta be at
a fairly decent level otherwise you end
up saying the same thing over over and
over again yes i'm learning arabic yes
that's nice yes my name is steve end of
conversation right so
i want to wait a little bit but
definitely egypt not only for all of the
reasons surrounding you know history and
and the pyramids and everything that
there is in egypt you know
taking a a cruise down the nile and
whatever there is to do i'd love to do
that not only even in stanley uh but
also other arab countries definitely
great
well i would also love to visit egypt
one day but i'm very far off from
understanding any word in arabic so
we've got a long ways to go over here
too
um but thank you so much steve we really
appreciate you giving a presentation and
answering all these questions i think it
was really i enjoyed it
awesome so bye everyone who are
streaming and watching um we are sending
out emails every week to link users uh
with invitations to calls like this so
if you're not registered for a link make
sure that you do so and um if you
haven't subscribed to steve's youtube
channel either go ahead and do that
and we'll be continuing to do something
like this every week um maybe not a live
stream next week but something for you
to engage with other link users
um so thanks everyone and have a great
rest of your week
thank you bye